I have an organization called artists
for peace of justice where an
educational organization that builds
schools in port-au-prince in Haiti we've
been there since 2008 and since the
earthquake we've grown quite a lot and
expanded our programs and i'm launching
young artists for peace and justice
which is our youth outreach initiative
we just opened the first secondary
school for the children of the slum to
port-au-prince it is the only secondary
school of its kind for these kids so
without this school there is nowhere for
them to go Pat sixth grade these are
students who show up to class and
perfectly press uniforms with their
books with their homework done and
they're living in tent camps they have
no water they have no electricity they
don't have food there is cholera there's
hurricanes they're still living in the
aftermath of a horrible earthquake and
yet they're showing up to school and
that shows me that there is this drive
to learn to empower themselves with
education and we know that is the path
out of poverty
technology plays a big role in what we
do because that's the way that we
connect with young people who want to be
a part of our movement want to start
their own spin-off movements with the
same goal Twitter and Facebook are
obviously instrumental when you're
trying to start a movement when you're
trying to get people excited about
something I was very inspired by the
Obama campaign for which I was a
surrogate and I think many young people
learned that their participation can
move mountains we're growing fast and we
need people to join our movement we need
interns you need volunteers the advent
of social networking is an interesting
kind of phenomenon because in the one
sense it's bringing people together it's
creating community but in the other
sense is putting people in our own
worlds and they're disconnecting from
nature and humanity so that they can
live these kind of alternate existences
in their devices so I guess the goal is
to understand the potential of this
technology and how it can continue to
bring us together while at the same time
understanding that our connection to
humanity nature and everything that is
actually real and around us is paramount
the world's in a dangerous place right
now so we need big changes in the game
and I think that's all going to come
from people being excited about the new
technology that allows us to connect
with each other and come up with new
ideas